avec françois asselineau président de
l'union populaire républicaine
bonjour françois sinon merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur arte france alors on le
disait magdelenat tron a parlé pendant
plus de deux heures cet après midi
certains membres de l'opposition
l'accusent déjà d'instrumentaliser la
présidence française de l'union
européenne à des fins électorales est-ce
que c'est aussi votre avis
oui n'est question que de ça c'est une
instrumentalisation politique que fait
d'ailleurs exactement la même chose
c'est madame pécresse comme l'a dit
comme vous venez de le dire madame
pécresse a publié une une tribune dans
le journal le monde d'aujourd'hui qui
d'ailleurs dit à peu près la même chose
que monsieur macron si le même programme
ils sont tous les deux pour la réforme
de schengen ils sont tous les deux pour
un partenariat avec l'afrique ils sont
tous les deux ils prêchent tous les deux
pour des champions industriels européens
ils demandent tous les deux d'une taxe
carbone à la n va aux frontières
européennes
ils proposent tous les deux de lutter
contre les gars femmes ils veulent tous
les deux vont lutter contre le dumping
social des pays de l'est ils veulent
tous les deux le nucléaire enfin bon
bref ccc ccc c'est blanc bonnet et
bonnet blanc fait alors ce que je
voudrais dire quand même c'est que vous
avez si je peux me permettre comme une
légère imprécision de vocabulaire que
n'a pas dit la personne auparavant c'est
à dire que vous avez de la présidence de
l'union européenne dont il s'agit pas du
tout la présidence de l'union européenne
il s'agit que la france va présider le
conseil de l'union européenne
alors évidemment les français ne
comprennent pas du tout ce qui se passe
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans
l'union européenne dans les institutions
européennes
vous avez le conseil européen présidé
par charles michel qui est l'instance où
se réunissent les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui prennent les vraies
décisions et ils prennent des décisions
sur la base de tous les dossiers qui ont
été proposées préparer programmée par la
commission européenne qui est présidée
par madame von der leyen qui est
allemandes se sont sales et deux sources
de pouvoir essentiel au sein de l'union
européenne et j'y ajoute la banque
centrale européenne qui est présidée par
madame lagarde le conseil de l'union
européenne c'est une toute petite chose
dans un coin c'est simplement la réunion
des ministres pendant six mois et le
prix le pays qui a la préside du conseil
de l'union européenne n'a absolument pas
le pouvoir que monsieur macro comme un
pécresse font semblant d'avoir déjà que
c'est extrêmement difficile au sein du
conseil européen et de la commission met
donc conseil de l'union européenne c'est
en fait une plaisanterie de garçons de
bain cette histoire c'est d'ailleurs ce
que monsieur macron et bien il a lancé
ça c'est uniquement pour faire croire
aux français qu'il est le roi de
l'europe qui est président de l'europe
j'ai même vu d'ailleurs des journaux qui
parlent de maquereaux comme le président
de l'europe il est président de l'europe
comme je suis comme du moine tibétain en
fait il est là simplement pour faire
croire pour dresser une liste de voeux
pieux comme au père noël si vous voulez
et de faire croire que ça va marcher ce
que je trouve quand même lamentable mais
vraiment c'est que que ce soit madame
pécresse où que ce soit monsieur mac
ronde ont encore une fois les deux
discours homps et quasiment des
décalques ça veut dire qu'ils ont dû
être préparé des hauts fonds par des
hauts fonctionnaires certainement du
ministère des affaires étrangères ou de
bercy qui doivent être dans des écuries
pour travailler pour l'un et pour
l'autre mais qui ont exactement les
mêmes raisonnements ce que je trouve
extraordinaire
c'est qu'à chaque fois il ya deux choses
dont on ne parle absolument jamais
premièrement pourquoi la situation est
elle aussi catastrophique dans l'union
européenne on ne seront nos cherche
jamais quelle est l'origine des
problèmes et la deuxième chose dont on
ne parle jamais de maquereaux n'a pas
parlé c'est que il parle comme si la
france décidait mais la france c'est un
pays sur 27 et je vais vous dire un
secret pour tous les téléspectateurs de
rtc que ce qu'a dit macron aujourd'hui
où ce qu'a écrit madame pécresse
aujourd'hui eh bien figurez vous
car la valette capitale de malte a view
nuss capitale de la lituanie à
copenhague capitale du danemark mais
aussi à lisbonne à du bain à vienne ou
bien encore à ljubljana tout le monde
s'en contrefichent elexon lentement
françois asselineau j'aurais mais
revenir avec vous sur ce qu'a dit
emmanuel macron
pendant cette conférence de presse vous
qui milité depuis déjà plusieurs années
pour pour le fric site
emmanuel macron parle d'une souveraineté
européenne une souveraineté des
vingt-sept j'imagine que que ça vous
parle forcément
oui mais s'ils voulaient ils partent du
principe que le problème serait résolu
voilà le problème n'est pas résolu
lorsqu'il dit lorsque main mais pécresse
ou monsieur macron postule par exemple
qui va faire lutter contre l'immigration
ou postulent également qu'il faut
établir un disons un smic européen comme
l'a proposé monsieur macron mais
figurez-vous que les pays de l'est ne
sont pas d'accord ils figurez vous que
la géopolitique par exemple ils n'ont
pas question il n'a pas été question ni
chez l'un et chez l'autre de l'otan et
la géopolitique de le de l'union
européenne ya des pays qui sont anti
russe et d'autres qui aimerait que l'on
soit bien moins virulent avec la russie
il ya aussi quelque chose dont monsieur
macro et madame pécresse n'ont pas parlé
c'est l'allemagne
l'allemagne vient de changer de
gouvernement
elle vous avec l'allemagne c'est le
premier pays la première économie et
c'est quasiment maintenant le primus
inter pares s est bien l'allemagne a
présenté ses priorités en matière de
gouvernement et ça ça va compter
beaucoup plus que les vaticinations
monsieur de monsieur mâcon l'allemagne
par exemple à une posture extrêmement
offensif vis-à-vis de la russie par
alignement complet sur les états unis un
monsieur paul ce nouveau le nouveau
chancelier qui vient de prendre ses
fonctions évoque même l'hypothèse de
mettre fin à nord stream ii le fameux
gazoduc made man également veut
absolument lutter contre les dérives de
la banque centrale européenne et
notamment l'assouplissement quantitatif
on sait des choses qui sont
extraordinairement important pour la
france parce que monsieur macro il
montre une pièce de deux euros mais
c'est pas ça qui est important ce qui
est important c'est que si la bce
arrêtent d'acheter sur le marché
secondaire les obligations émises par
les états du sud la france va devoir
mener une politique de rigueur énorme
dont personne ne parle actuellement de
même que l'on n'a pas parlé non plus de
l'inflation cette année françois
asselineau de me permet de de vous
quitter très rapidement de vous couper
pardon très rapidement avant avant de se
quitter
dans quelques mois aura lieu l'élection
présidentielle en france est ce que la
présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne
peut-être un fardeau pour notre pays en
cette période en cette période
électorale de campagne électorale
d'abord ça coûte toujours de l'argent
parce que c'est en fait c'est
l'organisation de réunions de petits
fours ça favorise les traiteurs et puis
les agences de com qui vont faire des
logos mais fondamentalement le lycée
nous avons passé comme ça et puis après
ça passera aux deux pays suivants j'ai
oublié de préciser d'ailleurs qu'il ya
un système de tri play c'est à dire que
au sein de ce conseil de l'union
européenne la france doit s'entendre
avec la république tchèque et la suède
qui sont deux pays qui d'ailleurs ce ne
sont pas dans l'euro donc au total il
faut pas trop attendre de cette affaire
je pense que c'était un effet d'annonce
on va pas trop en parler je pense
d'ailleurs que monsieur maquereau ou
madame pécresse ont intérêt à ce que
l'on parle le moins possible des sujets
les plus fondamentaux c'est-à-dire notre
appartenance à l'union européenne notre
appartenance à l'euro notre appartenance
à l'otan c'est d'ailleurs sans doute la
raison pour laquelle comme vous l'avez
peut être remarqué je ne suis à éviter
sur aucune des grandes chaînes de radio
et télévision française depuis des mois
merci beaucoup françois asselineau
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir suivi
france et je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'upm merci beaucoup